in the United States more than 100,000
people have been infected with the
corona virus that's more than more
confirmed cases than in any other
country but according to health experts
the country needs to do more to reveal
the extent of the outbreak to help
achieve that the US Food and Drug
Administration has approved a new rapid
test from Abbott Laboratories the
company says the test can detect the
corona virus in about five minutes and
is so small the size of a toaster that
it can be used in almost any healthcare
setting it plans to supply fifty
thousand tests a day starting April the
first and to look into this I'm joined
now by dr. Eric Fagel ding an
epidemiologist and health economist at
the Harvard Chan School of Public Health
thank you for joining us doctor is this
test for real it almost sounds too good
to be true it's definitely real and
these the technology has evolved a lot
in the last few years to make as
possible
and I'm still waiting for it to see some
of the accuracy measures because I think
those still have to be peer reviewed and
published but any test right now is much
better than the one we have ranked right
now which takes almost a whole day
turnaround and is only 30 to 50 percent
accurate so this test and is on a rapid
scale can immediately tell people you
need to be quarantined or not
is would be infinitely better and faster
in terms of helping us contain this
virus than what we have now in January
experts were already warning this
disaster could spread beyond China's
borders and you were one of them why did
the u.s. not take this threat seriously
well the u.s. was under a lot of other
busy things like impeachments during
that time and I think sometimes people
it's really hard to imagine that the
almost the apocalypse
compared to what people can want to
believe because it is almost so hard to
believe that we have this
a global recession depression upon us
and people being locked in their homes
compared to what was just happening and
people don't want to accept it that is
the reality and oftentimes the
governments are frozen and sometimes
they just want to you know keep calm and
carry on but sometimes you that is not
what you need to do sometimes you need
to activate getting the test ready
getting masks ready ventilators all
these processes should have done and
started months ago okay what I'd like to
ask you about President Trump because he
had first was saying this wasn't really
a problem and then suddenly he began to
take stronger measures under criticism
most recently of the two trillion dollar
bailout which came from the Senate and
then telling General Motors to make a
ventilators so that's all good but has
the government waited too long in the US
yeah it's initially him calling it a
hoax or just Corona flue and saying that
you know it's just a flu and you can
still go to work with it was just
absolute the wrong thing it was the most
this is the first time in which
misinformation came from the top and it
wasn't just a silly misinformation but
actually costed tons of lives you know
this virus previously had a doubling
time of six days which means you know
missing three weeks meant you know 200
cases becomes four becomes 8 becomes 16
or in cases you know within just a few
weeks we presently missed 10x or 50x the
number of cases and illnesses that we
could have prevented had we moved faster
and this is failure and political
leadership in the worst extreme so and
now we have this pandemic on our hands
and it's obviously the fault of many
governments who fail to react and we're
paying the you were speaking of many
governments being involved how is the
world well sorry for interrupting you
there you were talking about many
governments being involved how is the
world overall dealing with kovat 19 in
country
country's fix it alone yeah so in terms
of vaccine production vaccines will be
the ultimate solution for it but vaccine
unfortunately is still about one year to
18 months away maybe we can find drugs
that will work much sooner within five
to six months of ramp up but all these
kind of things takes international
collaboration and in terms of supplies
actually Germany is actually the number
one source for reagents to conduct a
laboratory test in which we have a
global shortage alone and all these
supply chains from masks and ventilators
all these things require global supply
chains and this is why the world has to
come together not get caught up in trade
disputes and tariffs this is the time to
for us to come together as a human race
to create a Manhattan Project to solve
this epidemic before it kills millions a
global problem requiring a global answer
then dr. Eric Fagel ding epidemiologist
and health economist at the Harvard Chan
School Public Health thank you for that